crusader kings makes me feel like a
smooth brained idiot
but honestly that's one of the reasons
why even in its most confusing and
convoluted moments
i still enjoy my time as a virtual ruler
recently i got some time with a preview
build of crusader kings 3 and i want to
share what i found from a couple days of
playing
there are a number of new additions in
the third iteration and a plethora of
quality of life changes
and i'll tell you this all through the
experiences of being a viking lord
ruler of the holy roman empire and
accidentally getting my
leg chopped off by a court physician now
like i said earlier these games quite
often make me feel like a dum-dum
many of the paradox franchises from
crusader kings to hearts of iron are
packed with complex mechanics
and concepts that while cleverly tied to
their historical setting
can be confusing the first thing that
struck me about crusader kings 3 was the
improvements to getting players
acclimated
while i expected my first hours to be
getting caught up in a web of menus and
trying to get my head around abstract
kingdom management its introduction was
worlds more accessible and
understandable than previous games have
been
while you're still able to jump in at
the deep end and start your lineage as
you see fit
ck3 also gives you the option to start
in the shallows
the fleshed-out tutorial following the
rise of the kingdom of ireland does a
great job of introducing new mechanics
to seasoned players
as well as serve as a good starting
point for newly crowned kings and queens
no more going to youtube to figure out
just what the hell a casus belly is
this used tab system now puts
information that you used to have to
hunt for at the forefront of your
interface
collating all the important and often
obscure details somewhere that is more
immediately apparent
and available at the click of a button
the guidance the game gives you is much
more reactive
keeping suggestions pertinent to your
current situation while also giving you
tips
on how to drive your kingdom forward
while experienced players may choose to
ignore this
with my moderate exposure to the series
it was extremely welcome to have what
felt like a virtual assistant
keeping tabs on all of the dozens of
whirling cogs driving events forward
[Music]
the most interesting aspects of how ck3
presents information to the player
however is how
tool tips flow and overlap with each
other almost like a teacher guiding you
through a lesson
now subjects of importance or concepts
that may need some explanation are
presented as a summary window containing
the exact surface level information you
need
if within that summary there are other
concepts you need to know more about or
there are connected mechanics they touch
upon
you can lock these guiding windows into
a cascade of information
that is being drip fed to you all at
your own pace and
to a depth of detail that you feel
comfortable with this method of peering
into the inner workings of the game is
in my opinion
a big step forward in how the franchise
teaches its players
instead of getting info dumps you are
able to see exactly how each idea and
option relates to each other
allowing you to go as deep or as
detailed as you need in order to address
the particular problem or make a
decision
now this accessibility has not dulled
the high level intrigue or complexity
that grand strategy players gravitate
towards
if anything there is much more of it now
it's just that little bit easier for
power-hungry rulers to seek their teeth
into elaborate schemes now i still got
lost and confused from time to time but
it was nice to at least be given the
opportunity to keep track of each moving
part
and have a path to figure out how to dig
my way out of trouble
battles have also grown to become much
more alive dynamic and understandable
also featuring the addition of knights
that exist as characters within the
lands that you rule and
fight alongside your peasant levy as
well as your other more well trained
units
they are able to improve the strength of
your force to a huge degree with their
own prowess skill
fighting against enemy knight characters
and potentially turning a losing battle
in your favor
or using their commander-specific skills
to increase your odds of victory
in the right moment they can even
prevent you from losing a battle that
would have cost you a whole war
having these elite units act like heroes
can not only make a huge difference to
your victories
if managed properly but the ability to
interact with them outside of the combat
encounters makes your military feel like
much more of a living entity
rather than simply a number of men to
call upon for an invasion
or a holy war many other elements have
also been altered to make you feel
closer to your troops
and for them to have more impact on your
playthrough as a whole
religions and faiths can alter depending
on their sizes and influence
for example a religion spanning
continents is no longer able to simply
stagnate
but its size and how fervorous its
worshippers are can make it more
susceptible to heresies
which then prevents further challenges
as well as options to quell uprisings or
convert yourself
smaller religions can also influence and
spread much easier now
which can make petty kingdoms with
different faiths cause problems for
larger empires
and while your faith is one of the
backbones to your kingdom the way
technology is tied to your culture and
how those mix
also provides more options as your
campaign progresses
while you're able to alter your
interests between the technology that is
available during your rule
being exposed to other cultures through
marriage or alliances
can also bring with it the inventions
discoveries and tech from the wider
corners of the world but the main thing
that really drew me into crusader kings
3 is that increased focus on the rpg
elements of building your character and
your dynasty
the actions that you take continue to
influence how your ruler develops
and you also have the ability to develop
your characteristics through the use of
a skill tree
giving you the opportunity to place more
focus on specific abilities
stats and perks these can then open more
options when it comes to random events
that will appear during your reign
and whether you want to create a raiding
viking lord and build your way through
military trees
or craft an infamous torturer king free
of the stresses or debuffs that go along
with burning some poor heretic at the
stake
now there are even more options
available to you visually the biggest
difference is that not only does the
game look a lot shinier
but having 3d portraits of each
character further develops the
connection you have
to not only your ruler but to the
characters you meet and add to your
court
and while it's all well and good seeing
everyone looking nice and pretty each
portrait is dynamic so they will change
depending on not only their age but if
they are afflicted by an illness or if
they are wounded in battle
their visage will also be influenced by
the genetics of their bloodline
in a much deeper way this time round and
although i've yet to see an unfaithful
spouse be exposed by the appearance of a
fair-haired child
i'm certainly working on it spouses are
now more useful in crusader kings 3
having their own council slot
and this can be better utilized in
managing your kingdom rather than it
being basically a marriage for political
gain or alliances
as a result it means that it is much
easier for you to feel attached to the
important figures in your campaign
and will more acutely feel that
heartbreak when they get assassinated
or die of gout as you continue to build
your character with more freedom
as well as more player driven direction
it becomes much
easier to craft the amazing stories the
crusader king series is known for the
bizarre events that appear through your
game or the narrative you craft around
yourself as the world you build
continues to grow alongside your story
and feel far more compelling as a result
sharing in twisted tales of intrigue
like catching my murderous spouse
realizing my child is my brother's and
then dying of stress
or having my new court physician trying
to cure my gouty foot
by cutting off my entire leg for me this
has always been my favorite part of
crusader kings
the opportunity to weave your own
narrative tapestry even if it ends up
being full of holes
is one of the major draws of crusader
kings and the third game aims to make it
easier
and deeper based on what i played the
increased focus on accessibility does
nothing to take away
from the complexity that this series is
known for but uses that accessibility to
hook you in
and get you started and utilizes new rpg
elements to make you want to keep
playing
i'm excited to get back to my throne and
dig into more of the game
when it eventually releases later this
year thank you so much for watching my
preview of crusader kings 3.
if you have any further questions feel
free to leave them in the comments or
tweet at me at a regular dave
and for more crusader kings 3 coverage
make sure you subscribe
to gamespot
you